some important reminders if you are
celebrating New Year's on the strip and
plan to head out there no glass or metal
containers allowed on the Strip that
night that means also no coolers no
strollers no bag that's larger than a
tote bag so ladies pay attention to that
and if you are under the age of 18 you
need to be with a parent or you're going
to be sent home and of course even if
you're not heading to the strip or
downtown it is so important to be safe
to get around absolutely everything like
that one of the challenges of New Year's
Eve is getting around and then when you
get to the destination finding a place
to park yeah that's a problem of course
and it is going to be cold so if you're
heading down there to be inside one of
the resorts keep in mind they do close
their doors Candace Charles gonna join
us live here just going to break down
everything that you need to know if
you're headed to this trip hi Candace
good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
that's it will be bustling with people
down here on the strip in downtown so
you need to figure out how you're going
to get around and there are a few
options there will be free Transit rides
on all 39 routes from 6 PM New Year's
Eve to 9 A.M Sunday New Year's Day the
ride Shares are an option pickups are
usually near Casino or hotel entries
Lyft is offering a five dollar discount
you can use
Nye Safe Ride 2022 starting at 6 pm
today until Monday at 6 a.m but if you
must drive most strip valet and self
parking garages are expected to be full
by 5 PM there's free parking at a number
of hotels and casinos including Circus
Circus Treasure Island now paid parking
on New Year's Eve fees range from one
dollar to 30 bucks a day downtown for
the time middle of your life festival
will take place on the free monster
experience we'll be close to the public
at five
the seven block stretch has closures
starting today on Bridger Avenue from
third to Casino Center and third from
bridge of Carson Avenues and they won't
reopen until six on Sunday remember you
will not be able to leave parking lots
until well after midnight so take a
photo of the garage floor where you
parked but most importantly folks have
fun and be ready for the huge crowd the
cold and possibly the rain
sorry it's very excited yeah obviously
like bit nervous about the amount of
people but ultimately as part of the
part of the thing in there to enjoy it
and get to watch the fireworks with lots
of other people doing the same thing
absolutely and it will be a huge
fireworks show here on the Strip eight
minutes shooting from the top eight of
the hotels on this trip and of course we
got to cover what the latest as well all
the excitement on our lives Vegas live
New Year's Eve show of course if you
miss any of these details we're going to
be reiterating them all day but if you
missed any of them you can go to our
website to catch it all in isnow.com for
now live from Las Vegas strip I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now